تفاصيل الميدانيه وتطوراتها نتابعها الان
على الخارطه الميدانيه مع محمود سبق محمود
شكرا سفيان
اذا مع اتساع الحديث عن الهجوم المضاده
المرتقب للجيش الاوكراني للاستعاده المزيد
من الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في
اوكرانيا طبعا على غرار ما حدث في العام
الماضي في خرسون وخا تتسع الان وتيره
العمليات العسكريه لتشهد زياده كبيره من
حيث الكم والنوع ايضا نبدا من العاصمه
التي تقول سلطاتها انها شهدت هجوم الليليا
بمسيارات ايرانيه من طراز شاهد هو الاوسع
منذ بدايه الحرب عشرات المسيرات حلقت في
سماء العاصمه لكن اللافت هو اعلان الجيش
الاوكراني ان قواته اسقطت 36 مسيره وهذا
التطور اللافت هنا يكون مرتبطا عاده بعده
منظومات دفاع جويه غربيه ربما استلمتها
خلال الاشهر الماضيه طبعا المصادر الرسميه
الاوكرانيه تحدثت عن اضرار في مطار كييف
في مباني اخرى لكنها قالت ان هذه الاضرار
ناجمه عن اسقاط هذه المسيرات التي
تشاهدونها هنا وتكون عاده محمله بكميات
كبيره من المواد المتفجرات بالتزامن مع
هذا هناك تطور اخر جديد يتمثل في استخدام
روسيا للقاذفات الاستراتيجيه معروف ان هذه
القاذفات طائرات ضخمه قادره على حمل
اطنان من الاسلحه والوقود وايصالها ايضا
الى النقاط البعيده وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
قالت انها استهدفت بصواريخ موجهه من هذه
القاذفات من وصفتهم بالمرتزقه الاجانب هنا
في خاركيف الجيش الاوكراني قال ان الهجوم
الصاروخي واسع النطاق بالقاذفات
استراتيجيه استهدف اوديسا ايضا هنا في
الجنوب ثمانيه صاروخ على ثمانيه صواريخ
على الاقل اطلقت على اوديسا وقال الجيش
الاوكراني انه اسقط بعض هذه الصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه ايضا هذا الهجوم الواسع على
اوديسا هنا جنوبا ياتي بعد اعلان وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه
اطلقت 23 مسيره باتجاه القرم هنا من
الجنوب موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي قال ان
ثلاثه اسراب من الطائرات المسيره اطلقت من
مناطق في الجنوب من بينها اوديسا وطبعا
راى الموقع ان ازدياد هذه الطائرات
المسيره وهجماتها قد يكون مؤشرا على
الاستعداد الاوكراني لهجوم مضاد على على
للمناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا